but let me let me show you guys a video
i want to show you a video neither one
of you guys have seen it i haven't sent
it to you i only sent it to kai
so we had uh uh uh who what was the show
that was canceled a year ago
uh what was the show called live say
you hit your mind oh yeah live live pd
got cancelled right remember live peter
when he got canceled
deputy mark or something like that right
when he got canceled
sheriff mark lam so when he got canceled
we brought him on
and i said what do you think about
defund police and he said defund police
is a bunch of crap what are you gonna do
when you call the cops and all this
other stuff and he's like
so people who are you know were
supportive of defund police send me
emails saying what are you talking about
you know you know
all you think about is all cops are
right and all this others i said no i
actually have had bad experiences with
cops and i've had good experience with
cops
but more of my experiences have been
good than have been bad i said okay
nozario a couple weeks ago
we showed the video about nizari who's
sitting there saying man i got my hands
out i got my hand that's the the
second lieutenant who's got my hands on
my hands and then we brought the
uh his lawyer on and we interviewed the
lawyer and folks who are for
protecting the police they said why
would you bring somebody like that on
why would you do something like that
the cops were right he was wrong all
this i said listen i see the story
and i want to cover the story whether i
agree or not
i want to see the story to learn from it
right this is
all leading to people acting
in a certain way because the media is
telling them all cops
are bad i want you to watch this video
what happens yesterday kai if you can
get the video ready just just i want to
get your reaction on this it's gotten
3.3 million views in 15 hours
so watch what happens here it's two
minutes go ahead
yes you are ma'am good morning which is
and the speed limit is 40 and i was
going 38. can you raise the volume a
little bit
well correct with your phone and yes i
started to record because
it's at my apartment what's your
apartment
it's at my home i'm just taking my son
do you have a do you have your driver's
license
if i mistakenly left it at home do you
have a picture of your driver's license
yes i do have it and can you call your
supervisor please
i
[Music]
is
that's not just a feeling you're a
murderer okay can you zoom in on that
for me
yeah thank you see how what she says at
the end is she a white lady
listen you're a murderer okay what's
your last name i can't see that there
stop shaking white lady zoom in on that
phone no because you're scaring me
they're threatening to kill me and my
son can you get me okay
listen listen listen
you're trying to threaten to kill me i'm
not smiling you're the one who's gonna
hold that still i can't see that
is this your car yes it is and you're
trying to say i stole my own car because
you're jealous
yeah what the why wait for me right here
okay
you're jealous
is your signature he's only citing you
for using your cell phone while you're
driving that's it
for him being a mexican racist what does
that mean
yes sign the citation man here you go
mexican racist
you're always going to be a mexican
you'll never be white you know that oh
my god
you'll never be right which is what you
really want to be
right you want to be white
in front of her son unbelievable wow
how are you processing this what made
you show us this video let me let me put
it to this who the hell wants to be a
cop today yeah
who the hell wants to be a cop like t
you tell me wake up in the morning you
see the
i can't wait to be a cow who wants to be
a cop today he handled that so well
every job
every job comes with a certain pride
that you want to do it right okay why
you want to be a firefighter i got pride
why you want to be a governor because i
want to make an impact why you want to
be
you know a media because i want to go
out there and entertain people why you
want to go out there and do what you're
doing write a book i want to impact why
do you want to be a cop i want to
protect and so writing
who the hell wants to be a cop today
what what kid is saying i don't want to
grow up
it's going to be a huge problem it's
going to be a very very major problem
and i've seen that screenshot but i
haven't watched the video yet so that's
unbelievable
is that even legal can you talk to a
police officer like that i don't think
she should be arrested and cancelled
both that's humble
whether she was a cop it was a cop that
ran up on her she's
forget my language she's just a piece of
[ __ ] she's a she's the definition of a
karen
and you're trying to murder me like
relax ladies i mean
and then she watched the whole mexican
white thing i mean [ __ ] let me ask you a
question
so who is to blame for that obviously
the sole responsibility goes on the
individual
yeah that's the 80 is her i i'm with
that 80
responsibility goes on there yes but who
else is responsible for that i mean he
put that in their
brains the media 24 7
cops to be bad then you have something
like this imagine that guy's going home
telling his wife you know it's freaking
bad experience today man let me tell you
what happened
i don't sick of doing my job like
imagine that conversation at night right
babe i'm sick of being a cop
i want to change my career what's the
wife going to say do it babe
this on a daily basis but i mean that
was the epitome of racism i mean
everything she was doing it was intense
and they they paint themselves as the
people that are
you know fighting the other battle it's
unbelievable wow that was intense and
you wonder is that
is that normal i mean do you think
police are abused like that on a regular
basis
they must be here what do you hear about
what do you hear from police since
you're obviously pro police you're not
trying to defund the police well i mean
a lot of them
is you know the morale is low you know
and they are on the brink of is this
what i want to continue to do
a lot of them because and anything that
you're doing especially in public
service you want to
you don't do it for the credit but you
do want to be appreciated well you are
working like a service
yeah every day they put their life into
absolutely yeah and so you know they
they do feel it they're
you know and they're on the edge of if
they want to walk away from this
you know because you know they're up
against multiple things psychologically
with the media the social media and the
polarizing uh
commentary that's you know that's a part
of their job and their responsibility so
um you know it that was a harsh video to
watch man
for anyone whether you're pro police not
pro police
i mean other than the i'm talking about
solely the function
and then i think about the component of
her her kid being with her you know i'm
really
you know that that really disturbed me
you know as well because psychologically
you know
what the kid is processing it also so
it's a perpetual cycle
and that's a snapshot of her day i mean
you know that continues throughout the
day and her on social media going on
what a danger so now so now so now the
kid is
14 to 17 years old and have a encounter
and is belligerent you know towards an
officer and then something happens right
but it all
it's the seeds at the planet in regards
to how they react who's who's the kid's
hero the kid's hero's his mom right so
what's up
my mom is like those two cops i got to
be like that to cops because the kid
wants to be loyal to the parents so
kid's going to duplicate whatever the
parent believes and that's typically
what happens
maybe i mean but there's you could also
be embarrassed by your mom like
my dad ever did that i'd be like what
are you doing
a lot of it you know that's going to
stick they say there's more caught than
taught in parenting
you can teach all you want to do the
right things your kid's going to do what
you do not teach what you do
this is catching the kid just caught
what the parent just did
that's pathetic to me to do that and by
the way again
who's the responsibility who is
responsible for that
who is responsible for that who do you
think the dividers those who get paid to
divide there's a business model to
division the
the division business model has been
around for a very very long time the
media business is not going into the
media business model is either to make
you think
to entertain or to divide or to be
controversial
change conflict that's their business
model it is you either are a very good
entertainer where i'm sitting there
saying oh my gosh i just needed to laugh
you know
you know how it's friday night you're
sitting there your kids are gone
it's eleven o'clock at night you're like
two okay you go to movies you say drama
comedy horror i'm like yeah i need some
comedy right now seriously
like 30 minutes and then you go to like
a wedding crash and you go to your
favorite part right you watch it for 10
15 minutes
get it out of your system there's
different methods to comedy today to
entertainment today
this is a business model divide divide
divide
and buy and sell and there's a huge
market for it unfortunately so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye